hola a todos buen día
creatividad tecnológica
qué será eso que será creatividad o
tecnología en realidad mezclar estos dos
términos implica muchas cosas
pero les voy a hablar de mucho tiempo
atrás
resulta que el 73% de todos los
estudiantes a nivel mundial
no se sienten conformes no con la
educación sino con los modelos
educativos tradicionales
incurre en una super alta tasa de
personas que no logran entrar a la
universidad el entrar o no a la
universidad no es algo que permita o no
tener éxito
pero este problema vuelve y repito no
radica en el contenido educativo como
tal sino radica en el modelo de cómo se
imparte la educación una típica aula con
un proyector con una maestra que hasta
cierto punto se siente frustrada al ver
el poco interés que los estudiantes le
ponen a su materia es lo que genera este
tipo de insatisfacción
pero hoy por hoy que ya tengo 27 años
hago un análisis y tampoco a los niños a
los jóvenes oa los adultos se les puede
decir que que lo que oferta la educación
sea un mundo con hitos superdivertido
lleno de juegos y actividades
eso no se puede eso no existe
y resulta que cuando yo era estudiante
de escuela y de colegio
estudiante en realidad pero
no sé si era por la metodología no sé si
era por el contenido
desde que yo tenía tres años con mi papá
que hoy por hoy le agradezco demasiado
todo lo que me enseñó y mi mamá que me
tuvo tanta paciencia y mis hermanos que
me apoyan
yo no era buena estudiante hasta que
descubrí la electricidad con mi papá
desde que tenía 3 años me llevaba a
hacer las instalaciones de casas y de
cosas y eso me encantaba nunca le tuve
miedo un cable pelado y me le tocaba me
cogía la corriente pero no importaba
después
mi mamá siempre nos motivó para que
hagamos algo más que estudiante entonces
yo entrenaba natación era súper flaca
un día descubrí una cosa llamada
electrónica
porque siempre cuando era niña abría mis
juguetes les desarmaba y luego les
volvía a armar pero ya nunca funcionaban
entonces
/ estudiar
y descubrí que había esta materia o esta
carrera espectacular llamada electrónica
resulta que la electrónica me encantó
decidí dejar de entrenar natación que me
encantaba para entrar a los colegios
entonces en 'luna estudiaba en la mañana
normal mis notas eran
terribles os dan normales como para
pasar pero en el otro colegio donde
estudiaba electrónica donde me hacían
abrir televisiones donde me hacían abrir
grabadoras celulares y reparar estas
cosas era la mejor fue la mejor era la
única chica también no dentro de un
grupo de puros chicos era la única chica
entonces eso generaba creación como la
más mimada de todo el grupo pero no por
eso quería decir que yo no estudiaba
después descubrí que ya tenía que entrar
en la universidad tampoco sabía qué
hacer con mi vida porque me gustaban
muchas cosas pero sabía que me
apasionaba la tecnología
la electricidad ya lo sabía la
electrónica también ya la conocía hasta
cierto punto
un día
con mi papá teníamos una moto una
motoneta pequeñita y le abrimos
y me empezó a gustar la mecánica muy
carreras muy poco convencionales de
chicas pero que al final del día a mí me
encantaba
después de investigar y resulta que ha
habido una carrera llamada mecatrónica
así que será eso me puse a investigar
entonces resulta que la mecatrónica es
una mezcla de electrónica sistemas y
mecánica enfocado todo hacia la
automatización de procesos y hacia la
robótica guau dije eso es lo que yo
quiero hacer eso es lo que a mí me
apasiona y me mueve
pasó el tiempo termine en la universidad
y pude entrar a una red mundial de
laboratorios de fabricación y
prototipado que será eso me preguntaba
también en su momento pero resulta que
el automatic el prototipado es la
materialización o la fabricación en una
primera instancia de una idea de una
persona
y entre a este se llama fablab esta esta
red mundial de laboratorios entran
fablab y la experiencia fue espectacular
trabajaba más que nada con jóvenes y con
niños motivándoles a justamente
materializar sus ideas entonces venían y
les dábamos clases de tecnología a todos
ellos y ese era el fin motivar a los
chicos a que no tengan miedo a soñar
pasó el tiempo y ya fue como que se re
un ciclo ya hice lo que tenía que hacer
en un lugar y un día vino un señor no me
llamó y me dijo oye tengo entendido que
tú sabes hacer máquinas yo le dije que
sí
y yo tengo un proyecto y tengo todo el
capital para hacer el primer parque de
diversiones para niños tecnológico
dije vaya vaya qué interesante propuesta
y cómo le puede ayudar quiero que tú lo
hagas y ya dije claro que si no hay
pareja misma salir del laboratorio y
empecé a trabajar en este proyecto que
se llama laboratorio mágico obviamente
después de haber dicho si yo puedo me
quedé paralizada cuando ya llegué a mi
casa y pensé
cómo lo vas a hacer
entonces empecé a investigar muchas
cosas empecé a aprender sobre sobre
educación empecé a aprender sobre qué es
lo que necesita aprender un niño porque
qué pasa ahí hay un museo de ciencia no
eso fue como mi referente y empecé a
hacer muchas encuestas ya preguntar a la
gente oye qué te parece el museo de
ciencia y la gente me decía no sé es un
museo que qué chiste tiene eso y yo le
decía y qué te parece si te digo vamos a
hacer un parque de diversiones desde que
yo decía parque de diversiones la gente
sea gay súper pero con ciencia y con
tecnología mejor aún en el proyecto del
laboratorio mágico contemplaba muchos
aspectos electrónica robótica física
química anatomía
e
el día que más gente tuvo tuvo más de
mil personas este parque de diversiones
y lo que me motiva lo que me motivaba a
mí de reparar después de todos los días
y cada una de las atracciones porque
terminaban un poco destruidas
que por lo menos una de las personas que
nos visitó aprendió algo pero lo
aprendió de una manera distinta y por lo
tanto en mi criterio destaque que lo
aprendió de una mejor manera
ahora les voy a hablar sobre conciencia
3 de conciencia 3d es un maker space que
será un maker space el nombre son
espectacular pero un maker space es un
espacio justamente de prototipado como
tal 100%
[Música]
hoy por hoy me dedico a trabajar con
emprendedores con empresarios con
estudiantes me encanta trabajar con
estudiantes
y lo que hago es materializar las ideas
de todo el mundo a un sueño ese es mi
sueño y mi anhelo y hoy lo digo en
público de que llegue un señor con
muchísimo dinero y me diga oye yo quiero
hacer un auto volador y quiero hacerlo
contigo quien le diga claro que podemos
hacerlo bueno esta persona debe estar en
el mundo pero bueno eso implica mucho
tiempo de desarrollo y de cosas
conciencia 3d trabaja en cinco ejes
básicamente para motivar a la gente pero
los más importantes creemos que es el
trabajo colaborativo porque créanme que
si ustedes no trabajan en equipo
solos no se puede pero en equipo podemos
lograr todas las cosas que nos
propongamos y obviamente la
experimentación vengan niños vengan
chicos no tengan miedo de abrir una
computadora ella se llama maría paz
tiene cuatro años y ya aprendió a abrir
una computadora a cambiar el main board
ya ya cambiar también un disco duro en
cuatro años
promovemos muchísimo el arte y la
cultura entonces también nos encargamos
de enseñarles a los chicos les enseñamos
sino que simplemente les motivamos a que
lo hagan y ya chicos quieren hacer
quieren pintar una pared de alguna vez
alguien dijo a mí me encanta pintar ya
pues pintamos las paredes de este lugar
y lanzamos un concurso hicimos bocetos y
luego los chicos en equipo empezaron a
hacer grafitis pero graffitis bien
hechos con arte que implica hacer un
boceto hacer una cuadrícula pasar no
vandalismo
con los niños más chiquitos hacemos
cosas como vincular lo tradicional con
lo tecnológico y lo que ven ahí es
luego el llamado el drone y el ratón
alguien levante la mano quien jugó al
gato y el ratón cuando era niño
y yo les hago jugar dentro nia el ratón
no para que le tengan miedo al drone
porque les persigue magnéticamente pero
sí para que tengan un contacto directo
con la tecnología
y obviamente el electrónica y la
robótica pero todo enfocado a un
proyecto que nace de la creatividad de
la gente
entonces esto que ven aquí es un
proyecto que se llama que es un guante
cita tipo lo que usa stephen hawkings lo
que usaba en donde si tu presión hasta
el número uno sirve para personas que no
pueden hablar entonces y tú presiones
del número uno te dice hola me llamo
andrés
y la otra persona dice hola me llamo
ángel y presionas el 2 y te dice puede
ser tu amigo y el 3 y cada uno de los
comandos tiene tiene una acción entonces
son objetos o son ayudas tecnológicas
que al final del día ayuda a una persona
real
es una persona que venga con una
necesidad y tratar de buscar y de lograr
la manera de que esa persona mejore su
vida
entonces el día de hoy
les invito a todos y cada una de las
personas que están aquí y aquí ustedes
también lo comunican a sus familiares a
sus familiares y amigos a que hoy
trabajo hoy estudian súper fuerte como
diría un buen ecuatorianos a que esté en
el aire trabajando y estudiando para que
al final de este día lleguen a sus casas
lleguen a su cama se acuesten
duerman y sueño
a qué me refiero con que sueñe a que no
tengan miedo a tener esa idea loca que
tienen en su ciudad en su cerebro que
les está rondando pero hoy empiecen a
soñar y no tengan miedo de sus sueños
extraños esos son los mejores porque en
alguna parte del mundo va a haber
alguien como yo porque habemos muchos
como yo que van a poder materializar su
idea junto con ustedes les invito a
soñar y eso es mi mensaje muchas gracias
[Aplausos]